Oh, my goodness.
I have so many questions for both of you.
Okay.
Okay, so, Kamryn you started selling your brownie mix
when you were five years old.
Yes.
Okay, what gave you the idea?
So the reason I started making my brownie mix
is because every time
when me, my dad and my sister
would bake the dry brownie mix,
that you get in the boxes,
it was just really fun to me.
And, it was just really fun.
Yeah, okay.
So you enjoyed it and it made you happy.
And then, Shannon, you actually created special traditions
with both your daughters.
One of your daughters sells beauty products, right?
So yes.
I tried to get both my daughters
to become entrepreneurs.
'Cause I just felt like it was really important
because growing up, no one told me we could own anything.
We were always told, go to school, go to work
and, you know find a job to retire from when you're 60, 65
and then live out your golden years and travel.
But for me,
I found that there are very important lessons in ownership
and I wanted my daughters to learn those lessons
through being entrepreneurs.
So some of the life lessons are being persistent,
working hard, being able to play hard,
the reward that comes from putting in the work,
financial literacy, credit.
So it's a bunch of things
and they're young to understand all the concepts,
but I wanted them to have a strong foundation
and being an entrepreneur
I thought would give them the tools
to get them through life.
I mean, that is so amazing.
(audience cheering)
I love this so much.
Now, why baking?
Is that particularly meaningful to you?
Growing up my mom was a single mom
and she wasn't a baker.
She could cook.
My mom made wonderful meals,
but being a single mom, four kids,
baking just wasn't on her list of things to do.
And I would go to friends' house
and they would have like baked goods and cookies and cakes.
So that's how I would get my snacks, at friend's house.
So as I got older,
one of the things that I wanted to do with my daughters
was start our own traditions
and baking to me, I'm like a math and logistics guy,
so numbers work.
And as long as you measure things correctly,
you can't really mess up baking.
So I felt like it was easy enough
for me and my daughters to start to bake.
And that'll be our, you know,
little tradition that we get to do together.
So they could say when they get older,
oh yeah we baked with our dad all the time
and we had baked goods in the house all the time.
And Kamryn, how did you come up with the recipes?
So I came up with the recipes with my dad
and we baked the cookies about eight times
before we got the perfect recipe.
In fact, I have some right here.
This is gonna go.
Oh wow. (audience cheering)
And I was wondering if you would tell me
where do you see this business going?
You started at five, you are eight.
What is your future and dreams?
Where would you like to take this?
So maybe one day,
maybe I'm thinking maybe I could act in a movie.
Oh, I didn't see that one coming.
Yeah, that was, that's breaking news to me.
That is breaking news to me.
Well, let me tell you something,
as who talks to my daughter about,
you know, being an actor or being in the business,
I think what's really important,
'cause I learned business skills too when I was young
and how to be a professional
and it served me really well.
But what you really need is someone looking after you
and taking care of you
and keeping those boundaries up
and keeping you straight.
And you're a really good dad
so I think that.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much.
Wherever these dreams go,
Kamryn's gonna be in really safe hands with you Shannon
and you're such a good dad.
And I think a real example to us all,
it was really eye opening to hear your reasonings
behind what you're doing with your daughters
and Kamryn isn't it true you get straight A's?
Yeah.
(audience cheering)
Can I please give a quick review of your cookie?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
It is so buttery
and moist
and chocolatey
but it's also matter.
It's crunchy
but then it also feels
moist and it's like
and it's everything that you want in a cookie.
Your product is just incredible.
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
Oh my God.
And I ate the whole thing.
So there you go.
It is so good.
Your product is so wonderful.
And if it's okay, I have a little surprise for you.
We wanted to give you a customized Drew Barrymore show
stand mixer in our custom yellow color
so that you could think of us when you're making this.
And also I just wanna throw you a thousand dollars
to see how
(audience cheering)
you and your father
wanna use it for your business.
'Cause I asked if you guys are gonna grow,
you're gonna need more hands and more help
so I just wanted to give you that
to spend it where you see fit
and congratulations on your beautiful family.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)